you what the [ __ ] okay [ __ ] off
hi the basis of all humor on YouTube if
you want to be a good youtuber you got
to learn how to handle your balls
they're gonna fudge me over so good not
good not in a good way don't take that
out of context
and then give her more sugar I'm so
trying my innocence is is very delicate
right now I need to need to cherish it
as much as I can
you're better they don't mind my
prepubescent cracking voice I'm very
brave and manly huh [ __ ] you tits
I mean fudge I mean [ __ ] I mean all
things considered especially the
scientists that accidentally fed me oh
it's your time I'm sorry that I execute
a few goes bad but oh well
what happens if I stick my whole head in
here Oh terrified oh my god
I dropped my Magnum condom for my Magnum
dong sorry I'm immature I just have to
start over again until I lose my mind
everything is insane in my brain yes hey
Mark I live in LA - how do you like
living I think they're forgotten how did
tranquilize someone because I'm pretty
sure I just straight up murdered her
somehow with the syringe there was so
much super herpes and HIV on this
syringe it is killed her instantaneously
long assed level with long ass problems
ashtag long ass profits
Oh chica bingo oh my goodness oh it
makes me feel so much better yeah yes
I'm going to porn my phone but not
everybody shut up I'm just looking at
myself oh my god someone someone posted
like something from Mario maker and it
says the sexy interracial man releases
his anger and there's more stuff like
that alright alright alright
also if you hear any gross crunching
sound that's because chicas in the room
and she's currently chewing on a bone or
that and definitely focus on the gross
crunching that's happening as I'm eating
all these ants and an eco-terrorist
disaster that's gonna cause a rip in the
fabric of time and that's a snail god
damn interracial sexy goof shoves bread
into his fury hoho this is when I was a
young lad very young and full of hope
and this is me mid puberty boy what a
difference that time in my life made for
me aren't I glad that I went through
that without any horrible disfiguring
ailments anyway
haha oh god oh god oh god oh
at least you died oh [ __ ] they're all
terminators oh stop it oh you're so
weird
I sent by you're not weird you can never
be weird oh my god that's amazing you
went right through the door I love you
put on the dad pants every once in a
while with chica you stay you stay there
you stay right there
good stay don't give me that look stay
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more of a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video